[Musik]
russland vor gut drei stunden die
hauptnachrichten bei razzia 1 die
meldung über navis vergiftungen schafft
es heute nicht in die sendung aus sicht
des staatsfernsehens gab es heute
wichtigeres auf der welt
der wassermangel auf der krim zum
beispiel der 85 geburtstag eines
russischen volksschauspielers oder eine
angebliche einmischung ukrainischer
extremisten in belarus und auch wichtig
italiens ex präsident berlusconi hat
corinna kein wort über das
untersuchungsergebnis aus deutschland
zum vergiftungsfall navalny das thema
wird von der staatspropaganda
totgeschwiegen
[Musik]
die russen hatten sich glaube ich bis
jetzt auf deutschlands zurückhaltung
verlassen
wir haben das zb beim fall des
erschossenen georgios in berlin gesehen
letztes jahr wo sich deutschland mit
direkten beschuldigungen gegenüber
moskau sehr zurückgehalten hat
dieses mal sehen wir dass deutschland
ironischerweise in eine andere rolle
gedrückt wurde
bei etwas mit dem deutschland eigentlich
gar nichts zu tun hatte zwei wochen ist
es jetzt her dass alexej nawalny
russlands bekannteste figur der
opposition opfer eines giftanschlags
wurde möglicherweise durch einen td
navalny am flughafen in toms getrunken
hatte
alexej nawalny schreit auf dem flug von
tomsk nach moskau klagt der
regierungskritiker über plötzlich
heftiges unwohlsein ein passagier filmt
das geschehen mit dem handy
der flieger muss in der stadt omsk
notlanden navalny wird ins krankenhaus
gebracht und ins künstliche koma
versetzt schnell kommt der verdacht auf
navalny wurde vergiftet aber nicht bei
den russischen ärzten gemessen an der
tatsache dass keine gifte in seinem blut
oder andere biologische materialien
gefunden wurden denken wir dass er eine
stoffwechselstörung hat eine
stoffwechselstörung navis anhänger
glauben kein wort nach langen
verhandlungen mit den russischen ärzten
wird navalny zur behandlung in die
berliner charité geflogen
heute nun die bestätigung aus berlin
navalny wurde mit einem kampfstoff aus
der sogenannten new york gruppe
vergiftet ein gift im speziellen dieses
seltene gift gehört unweigerlich zur
inszenierung des mordes man will eine
nachricht senden die sagt es ist egal
wie berühmt ist es ist egal was der
westen über dich denkt wir kriegen dich
und können wir böse dinge antun
alexej nawalny ist das gesicht der
unterdrückten opposition in russland
immer wieder hat er die regierung und
das system putin kritisiert proteste
organisiert und korruptionsskandale in
der russischen elite aufgedeckt immer
wieder wurde er festgenommen
wer sich in putins russland mit den
mächtigen anlegt lebt gefährlich
2003 werden die milliardäre die unter
putins vorgänger jelzin die fäden
gezogen haben
in den kreml zitiert michael foto kowski
der reichste der oligarchen erlaubt sich
kritische bemerkungen über die
grassierende korruption im stadtrodaer
kowski wird bald danach verhaftet und
verurteilt er verbringt insgesamt zehn
jahre im lager in sibirien sein imperium
wird zerschlagen und den oligarchen
damit klar gemacht wer im land das sagen
hat
auch journalisten riskieren viel auf der
suche nach der wahrheit 2004 anna
politkowskaja die investigative
journalistin wird nach dem trinken einer
tasse tee im flugzeug schwer erkrankt
sie sagt sie wurde vergiftet sie
überlebt aber zwei jahre später wird sie
vor ihrem haus erschossen
sie stirbt genau an putins geburtstag
wer den auftrag zu ihrer ermordung
gegeben hat wird nie geklärt 2006 tötet
radioaktive polonium 210 den ex kgb
agenten alexander litwinenko in london
das gift versteckt mt putin und
litvinenko waren beide beim geheimdienst
kgb litwinenko wusste einiges aus putins
privatleben und veröffentlichte es
[Musik]
2018 sergej und julia skripal der
ehemalige doppelagent und seine tochter
ein anschlag ebenfalls mit dem
nervengift now we talk im englischen
salisbury was der kreml von alldem
gewusst hat bleibt im dunkeln putin
macht einen unterschied zwischen feinden
und verräter aus putins sicht hast du
mit feinden stress und probleme aber
irgendwie einigt sich mit verrätern auf
der anderen seite kannst du nichts
anderes machen als sie zu eliminieren
vor zwei jahren noch ein weiterer fall
piotr iwf der putin kritiker der
künstler gruppe post riot kommt mit
vergiftungssymptomen ins krankenhaus
wird dann ebenfalls in berlin behandelt
er glaubt präsident putin sei in den
fall navalny direkt involviert das
erfordert definitiv putins persönliche
freigabe im heutigen russland wir
glauben dass putin definitiv eine person
ist die in dieser situation den
startschuss gibt
russland kritisierte am abend das
vorgehen der bundesregierung scharf die
russische botschaft in berlin warnte vor
einer politisierung des falles gift
haben man in russland keines gefunden
die suche nach der wahrheit im fall
navalny sie hat gerade erst begonnen und
die folgen sind noch gar nicht absehbar